madame monsieur bonjour vendredi 8 mars
journée internationale de la femme
l'occasion chaque année de faire le
point sur l'évolution du statut de la
femme dans la société
la grande affaire c'est la parité hommes
femmes sur le plan des droits en général
du travail du couple ou encore du simple
respect
cette année la journée de la femme tombe
en pleine campagne électorale en france
nous allons l'évoqué dans un instant
mais les problèmes des femmes dans des
pays comme le nôtre n'ont rien à voir
avec ce que nous avons pu découvrir ces
derniers mois à l'occasion du conflit en
afghanistan
si cette journée du 8 mars doit être
dédiée à certaines femmes en priorité
c'est aux afghans des femmes réduites à
l'état d'objet par un régime religieux
qui les avait fait disparaître sous une
tenue de fantômes et pourtant quelques
unes en tulle le courage de résister
pour conserver leur dignité reportage
dorothée olliéric jean-paul chaussée
adila et professeurs mais pour vivre
elle tisse indéfiniment de jour comme de
nuit pendant les cinq années de régime
taliban elle a bravé bien des intérêts
en premier lieu elle a mis en place une
école clandestine pour les filles à
cause de cela son mari est allé en
prison mais il n'a jamais cessé de
l'encourager je sentais que c'était ma
responsabilité je voulais continuer à
laquelle femme
illettrée
trois de ces jeunes filles ont suivi les
cours clandestins d'adil à la classe
était souvent improvisés chez les unes
puis chez les autres il fallait chaque
fois trompé des étudiants islamistes si
mon futur que je préparais c'est pour
cela que malgré les menaces
je suis
confiant moi je lèverai la voix leur les
autres à
ce voile c'est toi khaled et est
aujourd'hui ces jeunes fuient sont
libres d'apprendre elles ont entre 10 et
19 ans ils savent tout juste lire et
écrire officiellement l'école reprend le
21 mars mais elles veulent rattraper
tout le temps perdu pour un jour devenir
elle aussi professeur ou même docteur
j'ai peur que les talibans reviennent et
gâchis
madame amère elle a connu la vraie
liberté
la vraie liberté ces jeunes élèves les
fleurs tout juste en rêve après cinq ans
et tout fait sous une burqa bleue et
avoir la vie derrière un grillage
comment pourrait-elle réaliser que dans
les années 60 et 70 les femmes portaient
sur cette même place des talons
compensés et des minijupes
enfin sept jours